il vous manque fort
ccg un sentiment
parce que là je me sens tout seul et à
chaque fois je pense à lui à chaque fois
quand quelqu'un me parle de grichka
toujours j'ai les larmes aux yeux parce
qu'il l'a il aller là où il a laissé un
vide que personne ne peut le remplir et
parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de choses
pour moi il était toujours à côté de moi
de moi et c'est un sentiment horrible
est tellement difficile de
de ne plus voir la personne que tu aimes
que quand tu as vécu de très bons
moments ensemble
on a un peu l'impression jordache amassé
que riche qu'à occuper tellement de
place moi c'est bien travaillé douze ans
avec lui mais c'est une double perte
alors non pas parce qu'ils étaient 2
mais parce que c'était un de mes clients
en tant qu'agent jeu mais c'est surtout
mon ami mon meilleur ami est donc mon
meuble mon monde est un peu dépeuplé je
n'ai plus personne qui gênait personne
qui vient à 4 heures du matin chez moi
avec sa smart parce que je ne vais pas
bien je n'ai personne qui vient avec sa
guitare sur le dôme chanter des chansons
dresser des poèmes il était omniprésent
et ça fait bizarre de ne pas voir son
nom apparaître sur le téléphone et de ne
pas le voir de ne pas pouvoir le
rejoindre la en sortant parce qu on a
passé un bon moment avec toi qu'on a
envie de partager en tout cas voyez où
il nous manque vous dis merci d'avoir
été avec nous je voudrais juste lorsque
tu sais damien tu sais que tu sais qu'il
te considéré comme le troisième frère
ils m'ont aussi a doublé de ce titre là
et je ne suis dit que pour tu sois
vraiment le troisième frère parce que tu
extrêmement bienveillant comme eux il te
manque un petit accessoire est donc jeté
à mener non pas non non non on n'a pas
le montant mais j'étais amené tenue
[Musique]
là je vais la garder et je vous dis
jamais vraiment sincèrement ce sont deux
garçons extraordinaires qui étaient
toujours présents ils n'ont jamais
planté sur rien voilà je les aimais fort
et il me manque aussi énormément ça là
je vais la garder à vie vraiment c'est
merci c'est un très très beau cadeau